Four three,
two,
one.
And we're live with Joey,
Coco Diaz and one of the baddest motherfuckers on the planet.
Yoel Romero in the house.
Thank you so much.
So Yo,
you got a good grasp of English.
Pretty good.
Joey's going to help fill in the blanks and uh,
we'll be able to have some good communication here.
You guys did a podcast last night.
It's Spanish,
Spanish,
Spanglish and English.
We started English and then went into Spanglish and I just wanted to know,
I want the people know who that how Yo Romero was.
We've talked about Cuba and his humble beginnings.
How he went to school from Monday to Friday is of the pyramid and you're just
wrestled and that's how they do it in Cuba.
Then you go up the pyramid and now he only went home on the weekends.
Pyramid meaning it's a pyramid school and bleak.
I made like toilet Bekah said do it.
Um,
they'd be,
it's a system as soon as he thought might be down here,
GAM nps and then we didn't put on the hell do we can start started about seven
years old.
I don't think been an issue since then.
I bought
all the sports and Cuba start that way.
Wow.
And you go up to pyramid but you do take Ella,
Ella Luna,
he Rina that like I said,
you stay there for the week and they educate you.
They feed you,
you sleep to,
you wrestled there you wrestle one.
I saw that there.
Um,
I think I meant that you wake up in the morning.
Sorry.
Um,
she had that I'm in Ghana seven in the morning.
Don't,
they didn't without your thoughts on your schedule and everything is run by a
schedule.
Militaristic.
Sneaky.
I'm okay.
Then she after Cho and he said,
they say,
you know,
seven,
eight breakfast.
Yeah.
They all tried O'Shea and he said,
yeah,
eight to 12 school.
You went to school.
I've been there.
They started,
I know,
I said they got the Maddix
Feesey guy.
So everything,
how did they decide what sport you compete in?
Like,
how did you choose wrestling?
Was that just something that you loved or was it,
did you like other sports?
Like how did you choose to focus on wrestling book had to go hit the car.
I look child,
no Yo,
at the beginning I want to make it boxing,
boxing,
boxing my daddy and you know,
for the family,
for my dad,
uh,
his boxing and wrestling people is my family and wrestling and boxing.
But I love Brazil boxing.
In the beginning my dad said,
no,
it's,
I know like it,
you make a sport boxing because boxing is too much punched in the face.
There's no good,
it's no good.
But you know,
I'm in the beginning and make it box in Escondido,
hide it from his dad.
Oh really?
They say I need six years old.
He was boxing.
He would hide it from his dad.
[inaudible] little Ramos,
the Olympics,
uh,
whatever,
1980,
he would sneak around with him.
I been in the ACO man.
[inaudible] he will learn with him how to box up hiding from his dad.
Uh,
when did you focus on just wrestling?
Like when did wrestling takeover.
Okay.
Um,
and me,
bro,
ain't shit man.
That shit ain't made CDP not they're real.
And Man,
everybody know my family,
you know,
uh,
one coach for wrestling [inaudible] he sent me and then I go to [inaudible].
She,
I said it's not my Nigga.
We just sent the notice.
There's a lot of traders in the pyramid bunk.
I scored less,
they go to the schools,
I would call it.
I didn't go to look for talent,
you know,
he,
I said what else?
And they do try outs.
He had been there that I put her in bed,
but I got it bought it to place,
depending on what you're,
how you're doing the testing when you go to that.
So it's just like,
uh,
they go,
they evaluate you and then they decide what's best for you.
For the example you coached for boxing uncle for judo,
y'all use,
it goes down.
I'm boxing,
not quando they wound up something like this.
Okay.
We say,
okay,
we go to tomorrow for,
for,
it's cool.
And we as the people for the,
for the kid,
you know,
you're doing you,
you tested for the blockchain.
I do it for wrestling and you're doing it for,
for Tuck on day one.
You know,
and now you see she did she tang Tang Kid,
you got a tank kit and you see who is the best,
who is that?
Then the talent for blockchain.
Maybe you see okay for books in good,
there may be no good and bad.
You say you see,
you can see you say,
oh fuck bullshit.
No,
go about for taekwondo.
Hey Jake,
this guy,
I haven't to him for your spa and now you know,
like this,
that's his deputy diamonds and she's thinking Cuba.
You know the people take it when they,
when they get these are very young,
you know,
and go to that for that.
Especially at a school for spar,
you know,
[inaudible] the lowest level.
Say Yama [inaudible] and 80 [inaudible] there.
See and come and say Jambalaya Mosbacher the lowest level plan 80 and nothing to
leave my side until [inaudible] 80 either.
That's the second level.
The second level is m s s extra
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
So Yama is bought last year and [inaudible] that's the highest level.
That's the junior,
junior,
junior.
They were the [inaudible].
He stopped.
He said that she on us,
you know.
Then you get the selection to be national Olympic Center,
Olympic Center.
So they take it to a different center.
So you keep going up like until you get to like the UFC training facility.
Matt Brown told me that he did his camp for,
I think it was the Mike Pyle fight,
this camp in Cuba.
He said there's just tremendous talent.
He said he just couldn't believe how good the boxers were,
how good the wrestlers were was just unbelievable.
Yeah,
I hear he then my bronze thing Q I here for six weeks.
Yeah.
He's taking and and and and Masac.
Tony,
my brown go four hours.
He went to the highest level when he was down there.
Yeah.
He said he got worked some element you they're going to go home.
I ain't no good guys,
man.
They said they were good.
[inaudible] I think [inaudible] I see swipe okay.
He thinks he can't even go back there to that center now
they would smack him.
I said,
wow,
these are
crazy.
When you were there,
um,
Matt,
one of the things that Matt was saying to Matt Brown had tremendous respect for
the Cuban athletes and who said it was an amazing,
amazing system that they produced great,
great talent.
But he's saying that as you get higher and higher levels,
your accommodations are better.
Where you sleep is better.
Your food,
you eat more Food Loma hope gone.
Almost a Lamont my whole,
no,
no amendment.
Whole sci tech.
So a lot of incentive to them.
It's true.
Yeah.
See it.
Is it good or not seen the reality?
It's hard to say,
but it's a reality but isn't tight.
Brooke,
Gate Dre,
central Holland,
he went to a lot of Olympic centers all over the world.
He done
Numero Cinco numerous essays,
database,
the number five and number six wrestlers from those countries.
Core main domains,
more kind of no matter owner each the same as number one put on corners.
I see.
In Cuba,
it's not like that.
[inaudible] come on through up.
Ken threw chairs.
She had to tell him,
no matter what class [inaudible] number three,
you don't eat with number one.
He know.
He know why I'm stuck on the
same as number two either.
I said I knew.
I don't know what of [inaudible] the number one guy has the most privileged as
when I,
his mom,
it's good and it's bad.
Catch up then pull her out.
I said him out because it pushes you to be the best.
You want to get more food cart catalog Molla Molla or
cannot tell him [inaudible] horror and look at Stasia.
No,
not everybody has to be the best at what they're doing.
I stopped doing that and don't say,
Hey [inaudible] what does he and I go,
no,
I'm not.
Went along.
Goes down.
You're not going to have the privilege of lobster
if you look at house small Cuba is,
but how many great talents have come from Cuba?
Obviously it's effective.
It has its merits,
right?
Like that system.
It's a brutal system,
but it seems to be very effective in producing super high level athletes saying
give me a no trophies for second point is no chat.
No.
I said to stop and go all of them.
Nicole Holland.
No,
I meant down throw fade or shy CMPA and order.
I plopped out your but I'm 17 and shoo.
Shoo.
Shoo fails.
So,
so man,
pedal.
Yeah,
going to punto done that dental.
Get ahead.
The frail,
you don't want it.
There comes a point where you don't want the trophy too.
Ganesan thought didn't understand.
She entered me how to get it.
Come on and they'll get called right.
You want to eat what the best guys eat and you want to sit with the best guys.
Eat.
Okay.
The going to her foul.
I said okay,
go ahead and set up.
I don't know,
I got third place but who gives a shit?
I don't need to talk to them and they'll get it though.
[inaudible] if people see the champ,
you know the one to toss you,
the child that people,
one,
one is take them that well did it the champions day and I said what the people
want it.
And then number three,
number four,
we say,
I want to stay.
Okay,
I take it the Trophon,
I stay at my the like,
okay,
but I want that feeling.
What this champion feeling.
You know,
I want to wall where the people walk.
I want to stay it.
I wanted that,
that people talk like me.
They,
that when people talking to the champion,
that's what we,
the people that the system push,
you know,
that's why they say every time,
every time.
That's what I say.
Okay,
this is Tim Push,
you nailed this.
And it came my aunt,
the more that the guy that trains the most,
the system is,
they is the best.
You know,
every time,
every time you see,
look at this,
you take four because I stay in the national team for
okay,
almost
15.
Yeah,
15 years I staying in the Olympic Center.
Um,
you can imagine it is tay.
We did 10 guys for 15 years and the 15 years paying guys,
I want to kill you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Listen,
look what the song,
as soon building,
you know he did a Mooc.
A quadrant.
It's a building with a lot of rooms,
but I basically can aquanto conference.
Sorry,
look what that was again.
This is my room.
That's the rule for the,
I'm not a guy,
but this guy is the same.
Damn.
I said division,
right.
Any by,
we had told him he can see it for 15 years.
Everywhere you're doing editor,
where you eat everything we do,
when you sick,
everything he know you are about everything.
Hmm.
So you live with your opponents,
right?
Right.
They know when you're sick.
They know.
It's not like when you're fighting a Matt Brown and he was,
he's in Kentucky and you're in Denver training.
Nobody knows what's going on right there.
They train so you know what I'm doing.
I know what you're doing.
Ah,
so we're all on the same floor.
They do it like that.
The bill,
that verse,
you know,
whatever the hell that built in adversity.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Sally,
come on
Monday.
Do you know how you prepare yourself mentally?
How do you Dina [inaudible]
yeah,
bed dad.
I'm in [inaudible] you have to become a fucking machine machine.
But it's not only machine in the fight.
In the fight.
No,
no,
no.
My Shin and you live.
Yeah.
On the day when you're sick,
she died around a bit.
The had gone something.
This guy,
not only one,
he said guys,
you know.
Okay.
Do you think it will become a Makino
inferior.
A stereo.
You got that.
Okay.
No,
you have to become a machine inside and out.
And it makes hard as those 10 guys know when you're sick.
Right.
They know when you get hurt.
So now I'm training with you,
but I saw that you hurt your wrist and training.
I'm going after that fucking risk.
Right,
right,
right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's just a,
it's,
it's intense.
So that's why he's the machine that he is.
He says it only trains you to be a machine on the outside but also trains you to
be a machine on the inside.
And Yo,
listen,
this is it.
Very important to,
I am come for,
for,
for the,
for peanut Dario city.
Okay.
There you go.
Thank you.
I come in for the peanut area city
sometime.
You know,
[inaudible] going to go ahead and get the word [inaudible] with ages.
No,
not care.
What happened?
The icon
at the end of the second,
when we get DNA,
she see it that,
Nah,
I don't know.
After I read it out of this,
in Cuba,
you don't fight.
If you're 12 you don't find a 17 year old.
You fight somebody who's your age.
They put,
you're always with people that are your age.
He said,
Hey,
I'm not gonna think what else they call it categories.
You know,
I don't see you all.
I'm saying I don't see Lotus 11 or 12 at night.
You know,
corn,
the Yang I saw,
I knew even when I started doing,
when you get to the highest level [inaudible] you weren't gay by same
contracting company.
As soon as they moved ahead.
Alice,
you're going to find people with different ages.
He did.
He fit in.
She got this from different cities and Cuba and Cuba all over.
No,
no,
no.
Then Cuba,
they cool.
They said [inaudible] Quando yeah,
that's I'm going to do when you get to the room,
well that's ain't gone through I think,
but as soon as they all thought she was,
I think I'm going to come my way.
I wanna
be got caught him and to me more.
What do you could find people from those cities that you're going to fight
against in your own room?
Bought but hot Liza,
but and your song,
they all up [inaudible] 84 and I say,
well,
I'm 55 sorry,
knocked on Sunday.
Me,
my bedroom.
But look [inaudible] they said don't get there.
I know you already said [inaudible] know what I'm saying?
They're putting,
it gets acquired by [inaudible].
They seen corporate toner and each room there'll be five people.
Okay.
To Adams had been at the real to
Boston,
to Boston,
Miami.
Here's the new Yancey.
Yeah,
I think I not that room.
And the other room he said fight guy too,
but one guy is my division.
But the sand for you to start,
you understand no for the same city.
Right.
And now your frame for him,
I am not careful because when they stay in the room,
you'll see everything.
Hey,
you can tell him,
hey,
because maybe you the Fred [inaudible],
you're the best in your division II.
He taught me and going [inaudible] he has me pencil and he says,
wait,
who said [inaudible]?
So
you guys get to talk.
So now you always have spies watching you,
right?
For 15 years,
15 years.
When did you leave or deaf think I don't mean [inaudible] 70 20007189095 and I,
I live 2007.
How did you leave call number three?
Um,
I go to the grand prixs tournament,
grand prixs in Germany and then alleges
CT city.
Why is he sitting Germany?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
I own for four months before I think about it.
This decision is a one and Yemeni I know.
Go,
go about Cuba,
you know,
I want to make it a,
my,
my dream new life,
you know?
What did you think you were going to do though?
Did you think you want to fight MMA back then?
Because it wasn't,
I want to try it.
I say I want to do this one of these days,
but you never know.
You never know what they,
they,
the,
the life give you,
you don't.
Right.
But that's,
I now what I want.
I say the phrase,
I make a wrestling because he gave money happen.
Buddhists,
Liga,
wrestling,
Buddhist liquor.
You know what does that [inaudible]
Jeremy is a bond.
There's a league for wrestling.
Okay.
Yeah.
[inaudible] me,
me,
me.
[inaudible] she knows Germany and [inaudible] go ahead.
All the clubs will want to take them as soon as he gets a Germany,
right.
You want them to offer sanctuary,
right?
The office.
Yeah.
So when
you ain't got to see in 10 then got,
our motto was open,
he was broke and it don't tell you that he went about wrestling,
pedal,
knee pains and I said,
mmm,
is he,
even though he wrestled,
he wanted to MMA.
He was telling me last night that he would watch those videos.
People would smuggle UFC fights and to Cuba and it wasn't knowledge.
It wasn't going to happen for him and Cuba.
It was never going to happen for it.
Right.
So he wanted again to MMA.
So when he went to Germany,
he stayed and there was a,
uh,
an MMA fight and they wouldn't let them fight amateur
because he was in the Olympics.
So they throw them right into the wolves.
Like his first fight.
We didn't even train.
He's being brown in regards to,
you can see my dear friends fight with a habit as men.
Do you see what I do is I,
when I find the guy,
that's it.
When it happened,
she's not a line.
Can we find the video?
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't.
If you can find the video and it's in Germany,
in Germany.
And how long did you live in Germany for?
Six years.
Wow.
Yeah.
I make an Oprah cool like this,
but hey,
I started from the bottom.
He didn't know what he was doing.
Here it is.
Is this it?
No.
Dot.
Is that like a tournament?
There's no,
that seems like Jujitsu.
That's in one tournament.
But yeah,
that,
that's his tournaments.
Is that MMA or Jujitsu?
MMA.
Nice big basketball court.
Yeah,
that's what I think all MMA should be on.
All right.
Find out.
Um,
so when you had the first fight,
you had no training,
just,
just your wrestling wisely,
but you knew how to box a little from being.
Do you know anytime you can keep out because,
and give as,
as you'll have a grub as the people's okay.
Boxing.
Right,
right,
right.
I did it being in the street,
you know,
just fucking around.
Yeah.
Wow.
So when you were in Cuba,
were you thinking about the future?
That there was only so,
so many more years you can compete in wrestling and then what else to do?
One Who turned,
go to top and sign on your photo.
You had this huge wrestling career,
main goal,
new Trello metal than all of these international competition.
And I got in total out of that.
See what the office,
I know him,
man.
She's,
yeah,
I think gain MMA.
No,
I'm in Maine.
You can see.
Yeah,
here it is.
This is this it right here.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Wow.
This is crazy.
Look at throwing kicks,
man.
And this is no training.
No,
no,
no.
Get this wild.
Oh Man,
those are wild uppercuts,
but still throwing shots to the body.
Oh,
they give a standing eight count.
What are they doing here?
Is that what that is?
It's got,
it's got headgear on.
Interesting.
And what year was this Guy Daniel [inaudible].
Is that it?
That's it.
They call beat them
down.
We're good.
How are they going to let him back in this?
Very funny because the coaches,
he,
no,
not forgot about her dad books in the coaches.
Um,
some chemicals.
So I'm going to come,
he goes get comedians.
Comedian saw Jesus.
Yeah.
It's terrible.
Push him in the head a few times.
He said Betty frame for me to keep going.
It goes again.
Yeah.
Okay.
So he's trying to here.
Boom.
[inaudible] see you.
You in this thing.
It's funny.
Cuban language.
She can hear the people into the lottery because there's Cubans here.
Cuban population in Germany.
Whoa.
I don't know.
I hate that
big.
That are not technical.
Right.
Okay.
So is there a big queue?
Yeah,
there's a big,
you know,
where else does it?
A lot of Cubans,
Joe readily.
Yeah.
They all go into too.
I met this Cuban guy that goes,
I'm never coming back to the states.
There's a lot better than this shit.
Oh yeah,
good food,
obviously.
Sure.
I'm in Italy and he goes,
he works with a restaurant,
but he was a waiter.
They kind of understood the language goes a lot better than living here.
I go,
really?
Really?
And he went back.
He couldn't get a job yet.
Do you?
Uh,
do you,
how,
what's going on with you in a passport?
You getting a passport?
I'm on it.
You're on it.
Yeah.
You got to go to Italy.
Guy Did the paperwork and uh,
we've just got to,
I got to pay the 10 g fun.
Yeah,
that's it.
Tangy.
Fine.
And that,
that takes care of everything.
That was the root of all evil.
And it's always such a Sadie,
but they didn't care about the conviction.
They just want the money.
They didn't care about the anger management class.
It's just be the 10 g's and we'll rip up the warrant.
Fucking America.
So you,
you get to Germany in 2007 and did you find an MMA gym to start training once
you had your first fight?
Okay.
Eva Green Nausea I gain are we are sorry,
he went to a gym,
but there was nothing that was done
in a wok,
eh,
like I,
Yay Paolo.
He would hit the sticks on the street and shit like that.
There was no MMA coaches at that time.
Not when he was dead.
No young coaches.
The quail?
No,
no,
no.
Nothing.
No.
And don't say gay.
Yes.
Center.
I'm the top layer.
And don't say a,
he had them all.
I didn't check all the coward.
I see.
Get,
remind [inaudible] now the [inaudible]
he was,
he had a lot of popularity in Nuremberg,
so people get the word started getting out that there was this,
I knew charm,
but it was more because of his wrestling.
Right,
right,
right.
It's like,
no,
no.
[inaudible] and this club he was in was in the second division,
you know,
equal handle ain't
[inaudible]. [inaudible] or [inaudible].
So he started training the fucking fighters and the club one and they got up to
division one once he started his training to train him wrestling.
Yeah.
[inaudible] Quando [inaudible] Pelea okay,
you're way ahead.
They called him for his MMA fights.
You said,
fuck,
I'll go down there.
[inaudible] so now he started getting more,
a little bit more popularity in the city who won't toenail.
There was a tournament.
Damn Poco Mas [inaudible] a little bit bigger,
a bigger statue there.
MMA,
MMA now
tell her humping
[inaudible] day they chose not [inaudible] more.
I don't know the headline that got sick.
He May,
I'm on and they call him up.
Get up at Lehigh poem.
I shop on fourth and say I'm an owner.
I'll see.
I go,
they ask him if he wanted to fight with this Guy Sasha from Australia,
Austria,
Austria.
So I Taiwan pointed and does Anthony and let it come along.
This is a champion of 10 he app could air.
Okay.
So Hiv up in yellow,
I dunno,
nothing go movie ended up at [inaudible] y'all to make them come out the time
they can start to him.
He had fought against Gustafson Goodell and thought and said,
dude,
I'm Ya know nothing about.
No.
Okay,
I'm fight.
Don't fight the guy.
If we are paid,
they're going to tell him,
but it is,
I'm in there.
I ain't even if he wasn't for them and bought them and I meet him and me,
me,
they set up in there.
[inaudible]
they don't give know Quinton,
these two fights that you guys see or not his record?
Nothing.
[inaudible] the first fight on his record is Sasha,
the guy [inaudible] he was eight and one or seven and one in my head on by cyber
attack on you.
Okay.
Over there.
So he told him,
you got to fight with them.
He goes,
okay,
I did that.
Ain't pick up my son,
man and present the nothing poquito presence up.
And they had been sent the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] happened or he trains with a guy that was
like,
so type one though,
dude,
that had done stuff but not really.
Right.
Um,
and Siki Siki is set up.
You change the Serbian said it'd be nice.
You know,
he doesn't really know why.
Almost the puck around the [inaudible] after he beat such,
the guy started helping them with a little bit.
But you're going to do anything I'm doing like I ain't,
you know,
walking on the streets and you know,
you know rockets.
Okay,
come on.
[inaudible] I want to say how much he would trade in the woods where you are.
He was trending towards hitting trees and shit.
So how did you make it to America?
Because I continued to fight.
I win,
I win and I can try to do the strife for us.
Know from Germany.
So you live in,
in Germany?
I live in Germany.
You know your [inaudible] he was too hard for him to find fights.
[inaudible] fought that dude [inaudible]
sure.
The last at five but since he won now it was tough to get caught.
Right.
Well people thought he should have lost.
Right,
right,
right.
[inaudible] ground evn Okr
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
After he realized what he had done,
that he had fought Sashi realized Sasha at 40 against some good competitors.
Sasha was right.
So who does he start telling [inaudible] Alexander Gustafsson hold any young
man.
C'Mon.
Right.
The,
he fought either Alex or one of Alex's friends.
He didn't know for sure.
Dan.
He could.
Okay.
Necessity Alexander Gustafsson pet.
No.
Right.
He doesn't know if Alex lost to the guy or something.
Something happened,
you know,
almost almost [inaudible] almost what?
Alexander Gustafsson.
Okay.
Your top and those are single cause he was fighting a two oh five.
Hmm.
And don't say it.
I [inaudible] a lot of fancy.
I know.
Remember who he is?
The guy from French.
Okay.
The black guy.
Francis in Ghana.
No,
no.
Which one other guy?
The big guy.
The one dog.
I'm Francis,
a French guy.
Savada come on up me and knock them out.
Okay.
He fight.
He fought.
Who knocked him out?
Me or knock them out.
I think Frank Mir.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
He's two or five Chuck Congo.
Congo.
Oh,
another guy.
No chicken hates CIB.
Heavyweight.
Yeah.
Let me lay me
[inaudible].
Huh?
From France.
She's French.
Oh,
my fight with these two almost.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out who is the,
and this time,
2009 he's the number two and then Europe.
And the number one is Alexandre.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
yeah.
He didn't have no,
they would,
he had nobody to even,
they were just giving them these fights.
So you signed with strike force.
Yeah.
And then how do you get to the United States,
the United States?
How did you score the construct for us
when Alton Yonas manager,
not any
[inaudible] [inaudible] head on a URL,
say for one to you,
but you need to fire her fire for Yo.
She you want,
so you,
when do you go to the borough?
And Friday Henderson.
We'll go ahead and his own beat.
A half five.
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
I say say good God.
No,
be there half.
You know?
Right.
I know how to
write these people,
you know,
high level.
I live,
I know how men's fitness
[inaudible] was very good at the time.
Said knocked up chemo,
chemo after I think.
Yeah,
same level.
Like he was fighting a lot of people forgot about facial face.
Y'All at one point in time it was one thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I do your belly.
I can freak out and love you.
I paid the diesel and [inaudible] message.
So he held Rob's Phage.
I lost the belt.
The Henderson?
Yes.
Okay.
I don't remember all that stuff.
So yeah.
Yeah.
He'd been at Kmart came off beat at Moose.
Jazzy Fey.
Y'All beat dad came up and handed,
don't be that fixture.
That's it.
Yeah.
And so that was your first fight and strike force.
He lost that fight.
Yeah.
And that was your first loss as a fighter?
Like what was that like?
[inaudible]
normal.
No,
I'm not because,
because I say I
finished the fight,
then I'll tell them,
but coming under born,
he said he went up to the hotel and we went for a walk.
[inaudible] and again,
I may doubt him.
They may say,
do you want me to [inaudible] Yay.
[inaudible] managers are looking at him.
He was smiling as man.
It's just like,
why are you smiling?
And I say,
because through ad I see that I not laying I own,
I'm gonna come kill him.
But he was this close from fighting the beat and the grand champion,
you know,
seeing into nothing without training.
Yeah.
No,
he don't say [inaudible] he had a booth up.
What's the deal now?
He saw a positive,
he said,
[inaudible] Quando you enter.
And they made it that way.
He trains for real though.
I said,
come home,
he'll be the fucking jam.
That's how champion thing,
Hal.
So this was what was a 2008 nine,
somewhere around nine.
What year was that?
January.
I can,
he'll get flagged.
Why?
Well,
yes,
nine or 10.
Nine and 10.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
where were you training at the time when you came to America?
And I met.
Got to Tim.
Maybe you are right to American subjects.
That's the way to go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Maybe we at Miami,
he moved to Miami and easy fit.
A lot of Cubans.
C Yeah.
C
May just be nice.
Right?
It's c one C I love it.
I love it because they can mucho [inaudible] they they meaning,
yes.
He sees a lot of kids from his childhood.
Ah,
yeah.
Many people,
man,
which I can't tell.
They go watch.
I even cool a lot of mapping
from all over.
They fit and
[inaudible] even my home and killed and being in Miami
now in this country,
it's very difficult if someone's coming from Mexico or from a lot of other
countries to immigrate to America.
How hard is it if you're Cuban,
they just let you in,
right?
Isn't it a different thing?
Like they accept people that are leaving Cuba like,
Ooh,
I accept that.
I can say Elita Si.
Si.
It's easier.
Right?
It's very easy.
Yeah.
Where it's like Mexico.
It's very hard.
Yeah.
If someone wants to be a citizen of Mexico,
they say,
[inaudible] know,
I knew that it's tougher for the Mexicans.
It's almost like they're encouraging Cubans to leave.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then remember getting Obama before he left,
he put the no top rule member as a punishment for fucking Clinton.
Not Willing,
he fucking Obama.
That's why he was got pissed off at Obama because he signed the rule again that
you don't have to touch the beach.
Remember that shit they had,
what was the road was the road,
I don't know what the fucking thing was.
If he touched the beach then you were in were Haitians don't have that right
Haitians,
they fucking Yank them.
But all the Cuban has to do is touch the beach.
It's like fucking playing tag at home base.
But back one,
the new gold on
the bottom,
like Ooh,
may go cutting.
And Raffi,
he said,
well,
the head on a lot of people escape from killed a man.
They died.
That's a hard fucking journeyman,
90 miles on both 90 miles on a boat.
And they do it.
They got it to a science.
If you speak to those people,
they leave at a certain time.
They bring up saltine crackers.
I mean,
they got fucking like things that you never even heard of.
Hello Sir.
Excellent.
Sorry.
Excellent guy.
But he's the guy that got out the car and pulled last year and on Doulas from
Lou that some [inaudible],
some
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
That the stories are horrible of them leaving,
you know?
It's just fucking like 30 I didn't know.
Julio says it's Duda put up.
She threw me out.
I told her the day the answer is [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and it was chant down and I didn't all hell,
that'll pick up.
What's been your path to making sure all day?
I told her,
I mean,
you get to work on now.
I ain't took it off speaker.
What all we're talking about,
the different acts of says that you were talking about like the,
the,
the pain that all the races had,
the Chinese and all that.
But one of the big struggles is that Cuban one that they leave and he left the
sun in Cuba.
No,
his parents are in Cuba,
you know?
But then again,
I mean that's the story of the immigrant grandfather left Steve's brother in
Cuba and Sicily.
Yeah.
To make a better to send checks to.
That's their plan.
You know you're going to go to cute,
you're going to go there,
send those checks until Fubu for me that we can pull out his family lives.
Well in Cuba because of his success.
So you can send,
you can send money back to Cuba.
So what I'm on doesn't mean that she could do Monday at two.
If you send $10,
they give you eight mm.
See Amanda,
can you send $100?
He'll give them $80.
So they take a little piece.
He met Fidel,
by the way.
Really?
You met Fidel.
Can they say more?
They're going to do walking though,
where?
He's just sitting mass.
Wow.
Was that weird detail?
I know.
You know.
Um,
just champagne,
eh?
I go,
come on hand up on the way.
I can choose God.
He ain't up there Knickerbocker.
He's had two heroes in his life.
God and his father.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Elka Moon set him up when he sees a human being and he
sees a human being,
he treats him like a human being to try that out.
I do all day.
I ain't got my persona.
God gives town to people.
Like Mike Brown said,
they're very talented.
That's an okay,
y'all shit living on [inaudible].
He celebrates the talent of the human being.
The human spirit put on well done.
[inaudible] but he sees everybody like a human being.
You know what I'm saying?
So you just saw a fee.
Dowels,
a human being.
Do we stop?
He's like,
come on,
don't get [inaudible] core.
Got Epilepsy and then they paid.
He was a president of this country,
you know,
now being in America for,
you've been here for a few years now.
Are you a completely settled in you?
You,
you love it here.
You're staying here.
This is your spot now.
I like it.
Fell off Dao.
Who knew what
they think contact.
Okay.
Yeah,
no,
no.
You know,
Oh God,
y'all,
y'all make it.
Ain't no,
not that.
He's standing and he's already fucking state.
He's already here.
He's here this day.
I hear you man.
I say,
thank you God for giving me the opportunity in my life is here.
You know,
he'd say,
you know,
what's the difference?
How does it feel different here?
Get a lot of it.
If it ain't shabby,
just freedom.
Yeah.
Do whatever you want.
Yeah,
you have a future.
You have a future and have a few shit.
You formally have a few here
and is that
when,
when you have an exodus and your family,
when you have an extra then you country treat.
It's very hard and it's very,
and you have emotion every day.
When you see the SRO and you country and you people and you it to TNL apple
civilly to [inaudible],
you have the possibilities of getting here.
You know,
like you see this accidents and you see,
you know,
and we didn't see it.
We don't know what Grandpa Rogan,
I don't know what fucking Grandpa Rogan,
I don't know why Grandpa Rogan left.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we all went through this at one point somebody,
many people,
you lose the life in $10,000 to you eyes too.
And a lot of people lose their life trying,
trying to get here.
I said,
and he broke a Yolo.
I no without no beat Leicester because he completed that mission.
He'll never forget that they can't do an apo c really out.
They're not pass out.
I said,
exhale.
I see how they put in Mark [inaudible] and see how they pass by.
He said from Tennessee,
from terrace.
He was lucky that he didn't have to do that raft.
Right.
To go like the picture from the Yankees.
I had to go to the Dominican Republic and how to smuggle them out to slow me
down in Columbia.
He's had a sign them and that's the only way Steinbrenner showed up with an
envelope.
And then nobody knows nothing.
He's happy that he went to Germany and he had a plan,
you know?
Yeah.
But I didn't know why she didn't Docomo Japanese toner.
Holly,
you should do like 30th may see Anto [inaudible] persona who tries to,
they thought it.
He says he sits with a lot of people.
Listen to their stories.
Listen,
I see a four day before
do our own Walmart is that Guy Mikasa he went to a Walmart by his house.
Maybe the guy hit it started.
Maybe the guys listening to this right now,
uh,
[inaudible] want to buy food for his daughter,
for his rabbits.
Quando cycle.
When it comes out,
they all,
I go,
I know the money.
He sees him something not normal.
And through my buddy,
like buddy a guy,
the a couple walked into Walmart,
they were arguing
just [inaudible] he's putting this shit in this trunk.
Y'All,
y'all again.
I sent the quantum,
here's the Cuban accent.
He,
I'm them.
They had some problem.
Okay.
But uh,
y'all MCKAYLA,
but again,
no way.
Our glass in there so he stays.
So the problem doesn't escalate.
Okay,
Gotcha.
How y'all know about,
so now we tried [inaudible] and I said,
frank,
you don't remember him talking about the [inaudible] and so I took it out on our
meal.
They days that car for the woman here.
I'm like God to sit here.
He did got up there for the guys to hear a I said foray,
yelled [inaudible] says though the chicken deescalated,
the CIC left and the guy sat next to him and the car next to him.
You want my mom to a male don't move.
She was car settled up.
We're just closes the door and it,
they go more doses scene.
Cause he said,
you know,
I ain't like this.
He's all angry.
The guy next to the fucking thing,
Yo,
hold up in China and say,
hey bro,
Peter,
he thought was the guy to breathe and let it go.
No,
no,
no.
Come on fucking ain't nobody not banner.
It doesn't,
it's not worth the fucking anguish.
You know he coming to me at BNS,
Hemi emp,
Saint [inaudible].
Then I'll get the officer said he had a little car and started telling him the
story of what happened.
And then I [inaudible] your keynotes.
1,000 he has been here for a year in the states.
He met [inaudible].
He wanted to tell him what happened to him.
He ain't got a crusade.
This book has Beeni.
I could,
okay.
They Columbia,
he came from Columbia to guy.
I ain't gotta get us with dogs in it to come to United States.
He met [inaudible].
He saw two weeks earlier.
He had seen one of his friends.
Got,
we got [inaudible] from Dennis,
but he had been in the,
in the journey with them from Cuba to Columbia and the whole thing done
[inaudible] then I'm going to have that.
So he was telling me that that's the same guy got separated from his wife.
You know why?
Why?
Okay.
Nobody,
I mean I didn't,
I got out of boss because he couldn't look at his wife's face.
[inaudible] see young sexual [inaudible] in Colombia.
She slept with 12 men and Columbia,
you know,
pool.
I said not how he couldn't do what they say.
So that was part of the journey to get to the United States.
Oh,
she had to do that in order to get over.
Yeah.
Damn.
This is excellent.
Esrs the SAS
mini minimi potter and that's one like the minimal stories pocket.
Not
In core.
I say sal and Paul,
Paul,
the Ammos,
all they talk,
I said some are from India to Dev.
I saw you might [inaudible] Yo,
they did
in Cuba one week you leave like Amea,
your brothers,
you take off one week and then my plan is to take off a week behind you,
but I'm nothing.
But where you have no communication after you leave.
They didn't get to shut down.
I said
[inaudible]
daughter
and her mom knows
on lung consolidate from better and lessen Ba.
So did it.
But they didn't see us yelling.
Got Our [inaudible] on day that the brothers have found on the journey through
the jungles of Colombia.
They found that brothers called consists like eating like you know,
by a lion or whatever the courts corpuses he TNN can't say that.
Told me that Georgia.
He said eight.
I,
I know you'd have to look,
you gotta get going to get to the United States.
Christ is dude on HR.
But I saw your,
those deer take God,
thank you.
But you're giving me the opportunity very easy.
It's not easy,
but it's very easy when you look out of the rug.
Do you know he had little hammer?
I don't think anybody who was born here will ever appreciate it.
Like someone who comes here from somewhere else.
Well,
we all,
everybody in this fucking room started coming over on somebody.
Did somebody to some of your background or somebody did what they did?
How many generations have you here,
man?
My great grandfather from one side came from Ireland.
I've seen like the paperwork and I think the other from Scotland and somehow,
I mean,
this is what drives me the most crazy about all the anti immigration shit in
America today.
This is whole country is made out of immigrant immigrants,
the whole country by yet dental,
Amy,
Allen,
Americans total.
So much.
Any guarantees,
even native Americans seem to you,
they walked over thousands of years ago.
I can't eat silencing me signing oil,
everyone and everyone.
Everyone.
Yeah.
You have you done the 23 and me or anything?
I need to do that.
You know,
it's so stupid how a lot of people knock it,
but when I read mine,
I looked into it for a few days and you learn about history.
Yeah.
You know,
I have a little Chinese.
Really?
Yeah.
Because you can't me Dan Keana.
No,
spitting the bottle.
On Monday I went and did you have any idea?
You had Chinese and you know Chinese because the Chinese made the first real
thing.
They found chickens in San Francisco that had that DNA from that shiny.
It's very the worst thing you could do if you smoked pot,
it's spitting a bowel and get the report back.
That is a fucking nightmare.
Once you realize who you are on the do Mondo Papalia
who you can see,
it really messes with you.
For a couple of days I was rushing and you,
I was western African,
western Africa and Africa,
which I always knew.
I'm Cuban and you can't bring it up when you see a bar Cuban,
it's a black dude that speak Spanish.
Black Dude just speak Spanish.
They Africans.
Yeah,
so I knew that there's,
there's African blood and the top,
it's not Spanish,
they call it something else.
It's Spain and something else up there.
That's where,
so they went all the way around and the last little bit is Russian Jew,
like 2% of them.
God knows where he got that from.
But here's the problem.
If you're native American,
it can't give you an ivory blend.
So that's where we're really from.
Wow.
Nah,
probably with Jeremy.
But if you're American and deal with that thing,
they can't like my wife's American Indian,
I see her grandmother.
I was the only grandfather,
bro.
Fucking Indian.
Okay.
The mother got the off the Terry,
the Indian fucking lip from doesn't read it.
It doesn't read.
If you're Indian and unless you're a couple of generations back then my mom
knows eating.
You can see through it ain't,
I met a guy.
I know.
It doesn't have to read the native American.
No,
it doesn't read it unless you're three or four gender or something.
Can you got to ask my wife?
That's why she don't buy into it because it didn't tell us she was an American
Indian,
but the sister did.
So it's kind of fucking weird how the sister had a little bit more,
my wife's stole,
had it,
but not as much more of her Irish.
That's interesting.
You know,
it doesn't take a gene.
Last night we were playing to get this fucking savage,
fire it up.
You got to play the old school Cuban music.
I told him,
this is what it needs to play before he fights.
You should've seen them.
You should have fucking Sam.
And uh,
he,
he was explaining to Lee and his manager that if you know anything about Cuba
will fucking,
it was a slave mom.
It was a fucking slave market,
you know,
that's why they bought them.
That's where the white people went and saw a sex show while they were there and
took a couple of slaves back to them to all alibi.
Moreover,
the fuck they were from the reality of it.
So a
crazy
beautiful to be here now though,
Huh?
Dot.
Contento.
Si.
She got him.
I said,
why?
He say,
can I see how the output I met up with Danielle.
I eat,
that's what I meant.
The tagging,
locate your career and not just,
uh,
that to be here,
but to also be doing what he wants to do,
you know,
for people don't know.
And another job,
it's a documentary called something brothers.
It's about the two Cuban to live on.
Leave on Fernandez.
Brothers live on and do dookay come on guy.
One guy comes first and wins the world series and the other brother got
blackballed and cube and they threw eggs at his house.
Wouldn't Fidel wouldn't let him play baseball and on more,
what's the name of the documentary?
Brothers and arms,
his son,
Jesus Christ,
Joe Rogan.
And then they could regs at them.
They wouldn't even let her,
he had to play on the field like he had to play like,
like how he boxed.
He hadn't had Duke at her von Hernandez.
And then that mother fucker came left his wife and daughter
Joe Rogan.
And then this mother fucker goes up to New York and tears them up in New York,
like fucking one world series.
And then at the end he fucking wins in San Diego,
but he can't get his daughters and his wife up here.
So they got some reporter in Washington to call up fucking cardinal and why fly
to Cuba that night?
And they flew to Cuba that night and Fidel was watching the fucking Yankee game.
Jack.
And the cardinal game,
the known,
there was a note from Hell dookay saying,
please let my wife and daughter go put them on a fucking plane.
Fucking ticker tape parade.
The sister wife at the end goes,
listen,
I'm in New York and a fucking float.
They just want them.
I see all these people throwing toilet paper.
I started grabbing it because in Cuba you have to fight for a fucking roll of
toilet paper.
She goes,
here they are throwing toilet paper at the parade and her natural instinct was
to grab the toilet paper because I had done Larry Young for nothing Nigga.
No,
I don't know.
Young Kid.
He's like a thousand and boy,
I only got time for you.
I'm dope.
I bet they thought,
oh hey [inaudible] and go up.
No,
we have a bed there.
Toilet.
That's fucking crazy,
Joe.
That is crazy.
But I feel like no one appreciates America more than someone who was born
somewhere else where they're suppressed,
where it's hard and then they'd come over here and then they appreciate like,
I think too many of us take this for granted every fucking day.
I see it and it drives me fucking crazy,
man.
I see it in the drives me crazy and we complain more and keep getting more
immigrants and these immigrants,
well,
they're taking our jobs.
No,
there fucking hustling.
Yeah,
they're hot.
They have no choice.
They try the whole thing.
The country's founded on.
They drive an Uber 16 hours a day.
You don't find them.
I know kids didn't go to college and can't imagine they've got to work five days
a week.
Yeah,
we work seven days a week.
It's in our fucking DNA.
That's,
you know,
happy to be here and happy to how can be here.
Yeah.
Now when you were in Cuba,
the work ethic though with the wrestling and being on the APP,
that means that the intense amount of work,
that must translate very well into MMA training.
Do you think that MMA training is as hard as wrestling training?
Like when you were back in Cuba.
Good.
And Go,
Ugh,
Ooh,
after this discipline and you see bleed,
I seeing then get pay their mid Sotl you Lao and MMA Walla while escalating in
my Ludo and Lou child or the MMA,
they'd like,
like,
Oh,
you even going to be shot.
Do you know?
Um,
for sure did it dad,
that
the process,
the process for the training and Kiva,
uh,
of course he helped me in my career in MMA.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
you asked me about these mall.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
You hope because
you can,
okay.
So you see,
see,
you see the 20 is the Sam.
See,
he was the training for the sport is the Sam believed me because you can
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] chopper I MMA
training from wrestling for MMA out locate.
Why do,
yeah,
es Como Tu employee
Lynette here and upper layer and the go ahead and,
and,
and no,
no.
The value is how you use your energy and the two different sets of activity,
uh,
whatever.
So it's different energy for wrestling.
How you impose your,
when a gene wrestling and the energy that you have to have for MMA now,
when you were in Cuba and your training,
wrestling,
how much time do they spend working on strength and conditioning and how much
time on skill [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Sala and Luciana.
Joe
Did training is depending on what you have done that talk to me.
The goal where you goal is that that's where the training center and La La
Pregunta Nice.
[inaudible] don't [inaudible] it's a lot but I won't talk.
I said it.
I said on the last name.
When you go to train,
it's not a,
how many hours is where you want your focus to go
because
the system,
the system for the training is a
[inaudible] [inaudible] and [inaudible] and don't Akai been at our heart,
but she DNA.
What a hemp bro.
[inaudible]
when you,
when you left,
when you train in Cuba,
it's with a long range goal.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Nashville or not,
but I had a boy [inaudible] nationalists not pretty mad on a national
championship.
I said go and those that do not put two meters national championship and now you
didn't.
You need to see how you 20 for this competition.
How many,
how many
[inaudible],
how many hours,
how many sessions brought up to us to look at it.
The principal quatre wine,
it's a four year program.
The gamma [inaudible] to get to the lowest to the highest level and monetize
them and the whole world corporate cash.
One quarter you Olympic game.
Okay.
Why is it four years?
The Olympic Games you see every four years.
Yeah.
Sometime the people
walk about this,
know about this,
this is this the Primera you,
that's the first year.
There's a wound line.
You said that's a fortune
10 yet.
And yet the company,
not ammonia,
they don't win the first three or should I be shit or the championship because
training about it for days for the Olympic Games.
Then they began understand.
Yeah.
Um,
and Cuba,
what is it?
That ego and that is category.
That's why he told he stressed that it's true ages.
Two categories.
[inaudible]
you can't prepare a 12 year old from Olympic Games because there's no Olympic
Games.
Right.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] this who got the idea,
but you got to prepare for the national championship of his category.
Yes.
Our [inaudible].
You know,
you use the same science kind of man.
Men May totally mentality it meant I know mentally that Metal Barlow here,
no service.
He has old pal.
Oh wait,
what does that,
he's a genius.
This guy.
But is it the same way it,
so it's not just you're saying,
not just mentality,
but something else sees um,
Med Todo Lo here.
I don't know what I mean.
No,
no,
no.
I ain't go the pen.
The law,
they bend there.
They,
Linda,
either pendant,
they'll go.
That's how I,
depending on the goal,
on the age and depending on the goal,
when you were 18,
how many hours a day.
Exactly.
It's a laid out on that pitch.
I said,
Pesa at 18,
you start lifting this house at best side.
I did dental DSE say this.
She said,
Dan.
Yeah,
16 or 17 best time goes [inaudible].
No young kids lift weights in Cuba.
A smart,
and when they have you lifted weights,
what kind of weightlifting?
Like Olympic style,
the pest side,
powerlifting bestseller,
Olympic.
Oh,
Papa.
I said [inaudible].
I said
[inaudible] [inaudible] Dabba Hainan Island and let that back on the PSI.
The gamma last La Primera say say manners.
So that's when you start for six weeks.
He kept asking.
I said,
tell you I'm an eight.
A handmade.
I topples general orientation
with large weights,
but the vessel,
the large amount of,
wait,
wait.
I think,
but he made,
shall I say I'm test first.
They test you.
They test your strength.
I said,
when I put it right there to Bezel,
my weight can do nobody else.
Do you know what I'm gonna tell him?
[inaudible]
not a category.
You understand talking about that.
I mean,
Mac,
I think that I made him mad that barely fit in the festival.
We're from the same,
we're the same age,
but different weights.
Okay.
I think that I think will not pray wrong.
They give me a try out like I'm okay.
For example,
Todd bench press.
I made them in Manasseh.
He [inaudible] how can do their best work to live and die based on the wait till
I left my max like anything else,
that's where they start working with me.
She and [inaudible] 10 and [inaudible],
they got more love.
Nino de de,
de.
I'm an only hamper sampling Nino,
the 18 years heavyweight it then no heavyweight,
18 year old heavyweight [inaudible]
cm pounds and are on first toggle a hundred pounds and a bench press.
I will let the [inaudible] wrong [inaudible] and bought these trainers that they
have a fucking top notch.
You know that you're stealing money there must [inaudible] Los heavyweight
[inaudible] tilling only there.
They want to keep on doing [inaudible] [inaudible]
so they know when you're up in weight,
when you're down in weight,
they know everything about you because they've been doing it for so long,
right?
So they base you off that weight,
you do that thing a hundred pounds.
Now they base you off that way.
If you're a heavy weight,
do you still follow that system?
Now when you train for MMA,
like how do you decide you do?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Because you still obviously have a lot of muscle.
You're obviously still doing some strength and conditioning work.
You can get glasses them.
What do you mean?
[inaudible] Gamille and put a hand Bryant and allocating as an entity.
[inaudible] National Olimpica what did that one though?
The trainer he has now was the guy that made the selections for the Cuban
Olympic Taekwondo.
Ah,
AH,
okay.
I saw that in your,
the countdown fight before the Rockhold fight.
Yeah.
You were training at a taekwondo school?
So he was doing that in Cuba?
Yeah.
Ah,
interesting.
So he knows the system
[inaudible] he came,
he comes from that timeline.
The Rondo Yoga,
uh,
epicenter now [inaudible] what?
He started training whenever we changed everything,
we got [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] data format.
Let's work this way.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the [inaudible] onsite.
I know,
I know.
The guy had already been known for working with older elite athletes.
Like we've always joked around about Teofilo Stevenson.
Yeah,
I talked a lot.
Then you have the old fellows.
Could have been one of the best people set up a whole can.
Okay.
[inaudible] it's the people,
I think.
No,
it was fine.
50 I lost the whole,
they don't have fucking Birgitta buckets.
Right,
right.
So nobody fucking knows that so crazy that the geniuses have taken a 40 year
old.
That's why he switched with this guy.
Well
Louis Ortiz,
they go forward.
Deontay wilder this past weekend.
They're sending like no one knows how old he is a least.
Yeah,
at least.
So they have this older,
oh,
you know him.
So 41 for sure.
Oh,
oh,
Tj in Cuba.
Yeah.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Cause everybody was wondering like,
you know,
maybe he's older than he says.
Yeah.
She had never done that.
A quad ain't doubty Mimo Teddy night,
minimum 30 minutes.
No Way.
Teofilo to their therapy.
She had thought,
Oh,
I'm telling you.
No say they don't say nothing.
But see the thing like tico Steven said,
for a lot of us that are boxing fans who was,
we're always disappointed that he never got to leave Cuba.
No,
no.
We want him to see him fight Ali.
We wanted to see him fight Frazier.
We wanted to see him fight the best of the best in the professionally.
I these are not 11
he was another level.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was on another,
well,
I'll leave was on another level.
Yeah,
he certainly was at one point in time.
You know y'all could out gang [inaudible] he doesn't think Teofilo would've
been interesting to watch ballet.
She paid off.
Okay.
Do y'all feel out?
Anybody know what y'all feel over in this thing?
I just hired me by my sector.
[inaudible] father was a boxer with
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he will lengthen.
Lengthen Kellogg.
Lento [inaudible] he was fat.
He was way faster.
No,
cut out.
No.
Could I?
Okay again,
get deal flow.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
[inaudible] nothing here and I'm out of a movie,
but how he's [inaudible] hands
big trouble.
Trouble.
But
he moved.
Lucky Buddha fly.
Move like a butterfly.
Now you at 41 you look better than ever do all according to the annual
[inaudible].
Thank you God.
Crazy man.
Hey,
good.
I mean,
it must be a combination of everything.
It must be combination of eating right,
rest,
working out,
hard genetics.
I mean,
you got a great Ra.
I mean at 41 a lot of guys are on the down slide.
Not Learning to tie in the wall to talk to.
Ah,
so the door
regardless of what's going on.
Nope.
Well,
they had,
they,
they see loony.
They mentioned I didn't get [inaudible].
He can't say without that,
he can't do this podcast without telling him as a reasonably,
he looked so good and is healthy as the hand that God got them.
That was it.
Because,
because,
okay.
Japan being a summer [inaudible] the,
he's evil in shocked that how he looks,
how he feels.
No Sir.
I mean tacky frisee commenting not only physically when the coach this coach
Masala prayers,
when he does his tests,
look,
coach tests some uncertain levels.
He said,
good.
I forget.
He stays freaked out or a can't believe he's still okay.
Although we had calmed down at the tower.
So you look on
[inaudible] [inaudible] he had come down.
What'd he say?
I said that on the countdown.
I saw the taekwondo guy drone little fucking sticks at them.
You know the thing was foam sticks,
a false text and I saw him pick him up the tires,
but I never really saw him sparring or wrestling,
but because,
and I brought that out on the Mooc Guardian because he can't be talking too much
just because I make it that their blessing and Cuba.
Okay.
You'd Wa I make wrestling and Cuba.
Yeah.
Okay.
So he wrestles in Cuba,
you know the national team with a national team.
Lisa [inaudible],
Leo [inaudible].
That's why I couldn't lose,
he leave.
He didn't want me to see him.
You wrestling,
you know
and cool.
Why he said Lucia Con Kong Kong Chew Gum because the Olympics,
so he went back to Cuba to train with the guy.
That's to go world champion now from Cuba way you impact
your way.
I go into now,
yeah.
He goes to Cuban,
the tray.
You go back now see,
you can go back and forth.
Yeah.
Well I didn't know that.
Yeah,
I can't think a guy can.
Wow.
Is this a new thing?
Is this recent,
these new back then
[inaudible]
I don't know what happened there.
Where did he get out?
You got to fight with Wediko.
Cuba gave me the passport.
She,
we gave him a pass.
Wow.
I training in Cuba.
I go training it traded Miami,
sorry.
And turning and Kiva to we my father.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That must be nice.
So you can see your son too.
Yeah.
Can you bring him back to America?
This is different.
Yeah,
that's different because he's,
he his mountain.
When Cuba,
you know Cuba.
He,
he,
he hit it on the corner.
He's in school.
But I want to do,
when you stay in spring break,
he can come live with me and stay for a few months.
Yeah.
That'll be nice.
So that's that.
That must benefit you tremendously.
To go and train with the Cuban team.
I had 20 we did the CBA metal and then the last Olympic Games and we did,
that's it.
That'd be good.
What photos?
What was the last Olympic Games?
This last one,
but they arrest the last one was winter.
No,
it just happened.
So would have been two years ago.
Was it real,
real,
real release that I said in the beginning,
right?
Yeah.
And Real.
This guy,
he's as he had been met,
ain't going to drill.
He said 97 killers.
He's big guy.
Seven kilos.
What is that like two 20 yeah.
20 yeah.
I make it raising with him.
Hey,
why didn't,
why tough?
How nobody,
how long?
I know Louis.
I
work a robot.
No freestyle and Greco Roman guys,
they say,
Hey,
I have a 40 years.
This guy had it.
26.
Do you want me to see him win?
He feels good.
So what is your secret to maintaining all this,
uh,
this physical strength and endurance at this age?
At 41 I think it's just genetics.
Just luck.
Just God.
I think it's got the smart training too though,
Tom.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Yeah,
that's true too.
For sure.
Sure,
sure.
To join up.
[inaudible] he can't do what he did 20 years ago.
No,
no,
no.
See that's what people say.
Well people say about you is,
imagine if you were in the UFC at 25 or 30 that's what everybody says.
Like,
imagine if Yoel Romero was in the UFC when he was 25 Holy Shit,
I will claim that I knew my boss.
Like,
Holy Shit.
Uh,
sorry.
No [inaudible] we can't talk about the south.
He says,
right.
Of course we'll talk about it for you.
You know,
just she entered on being Joshi and [inaudible].
I remember when they have a 22 2124
yeah,
you were a motherfucker.
Can't take many people for the Olympic Center in the Olympic Center.
That's it.
The coach for wrestling.
I love this guy.
He pushed me generally [inaudible] now fairly better.
The Gullah Geechee.
I love these guys because,
and it's,
I call on me holding Deming.
He took the best out of them.
He,
he,
he knew.
He knew.
Take it out the breast me,
you understand?
Yes.
That's it.
Yeah.
When I training,
when I competed,
he see me like this exactly like this.
You remember when you come in here,
so
you remember this day?
He say yes
because are you up?
Yeah,
because that's his very many people.
You know these Easter in Cuba.
Okay.
MMM.
Yeah.
[inaudible] he was a little crazy
when he was younger and um,
yeah,
and being local.
Crazy when he was younger.
A,
well,
no.
Now he's,
he's young and he made a decision.
He domain come in and he took a path.
[inaudible] Mis Amigos.
He doesn't want what happened to his friends,
get all said it,
but he wants it to be this
deal.
We say kind of me,
which I can't tell [inaudible] his uncle,
Hazara Amy by Bach.
It was father Paolo Paolo met.
He had told them it's [inaudible] you seen what's going on around you?
Is it?
Look at the Getty.
Is this what you want?
Oh good.
I said it.
Or do you want to be this?
It doesn't get mayor hit the Hacienda.
Other courses,
you're in the middle,
but you're doing both things,
Teaneck and the heat on it.
Either.
You have to make a choice.
At that time.
We ended August who said,
this is going on?
What's happening?
He typed in,
they'll get nothing and phenolphthalein and you're seeing that they never end
right now.
If you chose this path [inaudible] financially you're going to have a final
ending,
a great ending,
their CT for the head,
but you can't do both of them.
All right?
You have to Amanda.
Then she's young.
He
even if he out,
I want to go.
Maybe had been at [inaudible] so he was living in Panada Rio,
but he fled to Havana by,
remember
there'd be damages,
the parameters you need it when they championship national champion Shit,
but up I side and spot.
So you have to win the national championships.
Higher level.
Yes,
but remember they,
they the coaches taking you and less as great as the coaches are taking you
right from the schools.
Well two Talento for your talent.
Okay.
Eat The Pawnee and less quite let [inaudible] and they put
you in a special school and most lower level elaborating and the basement.
Pray,
pray.
Hey there.
All right.
You need it.
When
they come with Flo Rida Championship,
you leave the wonderful,
really championships [inaudible] to get to the next level.
Broke it a day is less Colella principle Daytona,
Florida,
because by either as the main school of wall,
the floor was flooded at DNA.
When I ed um,
California [inaudible] they do?
Yes.
What is his name?
I either a day,
some different,
listen,
not be dumb if from on pyramid.
Yeah,
right.
Florida.
Right,
right.
The habit.
Nice quarter one school,
Florida has Jason say boom.
Don't even,
that's a second level,
but oh,
California Tambien Tiana Oni eating.
They have a said.
Do you understand is in total pies every,
it's an all over the country.
Dnn,
a this Si le [inaudible] DNA.
California DNA either.
Um,
I'm not exactly sure what he's saying neither.
I don't think it's a number.
It's a school.
How do you spell it?
And once I clear it,
okay.
Like this
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Denny Party,
Superior School of Sports Sports Sports.
Is that what it is called?
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
I go there.
Mia.
Mia,
what is he saying is like each state has a superior school.
I think that's what he's saying.
Yes.
Okay.
Aka December,
the second level.
Right.
And California highway one that the people want to do all the California one to
stay by.
You need a beat it the California championship,
you understand,
you pay this,
you win.
And now California the bay,
they are,
they are Arca and California taking you because you is the best in California.
Right.
You understand that?
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
That's in Florida.
In Florida.
Habit one.
I got to write that check to go.
Oh,
Washington,
Washington.
And why is you don't have it one iota,
but this is the best level.
You understand?
Yes.
This is s bar.
Okay.
You understand why you beat it everybody the now that you need a champion,
the union national team,
it's the
in Washington is I got to take it,
the,
the best guy union and the whole country.
And it's said now,
but in Washington to habit,
ACA,
but the senior,
okay.
I said,
now it's um,
senior national team.
Senior national team.
Yeah,
that's it.
And when I go,
when I stay in a d is in Pineda real.
You need it beating the guy for the low road,
Nino [inaudible] you need to beat the kids that are in all of Cuba and don't
say,
and Nevada and Nevada did nick junior national team take you?
You then they take your a junior national team picture to a violent,
you understand,
but you're noon car on it or not.
You're not 10 union,
eh,
they don't shine you.
He never won the Tuolumne county roles.
Allies,
Bronx,
CBRE.
He always came in second or third.
Never.
We never,
but does he back on wanting single uconn.
Ain't people participate in firearm?
He never one pocket.
No.
Normally be on me.
I called her because he wasn't living his life correctly.
I see what you're saying.
That's in my ma.
My daddy say,
Nah,
Nah.
So when your coach was telling you you're taking the wrong path,
you saw the results that you are winning.
I go to imam,
but remember you need a bit.
They Cuban National Tim.
I never beat it.
When I go,
everybody know this is this study
I had go.
He say my Daddy,
I go,
I,
no,
no.
You need to 20 here and pay.
Not the real,
you need a beat it in Cuba.
Everybody,
everybody,
everyone.
And now the coaching I bought,
I take it you can't go.
So now I go said no,
just no me son.
When you guard the people shake,
who are you?
Get outta here.
You know he went to a vagina without willing.
Why?
Why not seen
it?
I'm going over you.
Did she see a day 17 ah yes.
He say probably she said 16 going on 17 like I said,
they said it wasn't.
My coach is saying every time when I go to the fight,
when I training Jack on the yard,
I mean hardcore.
Once he became the best thing,
hey man,
see,
I see it.
He looked me in the eyes and ideas here.
You remember when you come in here and now you know,
and now you know and now you know what I say?
Yeah.
So when you were about to compete,
he would look at you and say,
remember when you first came here and you were 17 by yourself to Havana?
Yeah.
Okay.
They said
lady and square.
Let me Go pee.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Jamie is on the ball and square law.
The uh,
uh,
okay.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
So now when you,
you're here and you're training with this guy who was coaching,
he was a part of the Taco.
No program in Cuba.
Yeah.
What does he have you do?
Like what is a,
what does a normal week for it
right now?
Right now?
Yeah.
When I know big Eh,
big weights be wait,
heavyweights.
Yeah.
Heavy.
Like are you doing like Olympic style?
Like clean press,
like that kind of stuff?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Remember we make a desk [inaudible] the see where your results are can make it
this noise like a boom bro.
Nah,
Nah.
It's all system,
right?
Yeah.
So what you're saying is it's not random,
it's very specific.
Specific,
yeah.
He say,
okay,
and you did that kind of temporal.
Hey,
I it and bench press.
Right.
Okay.
And he writes the numbers down.
Right.
Okay.
You'll have it.
There you go.
And why is this here?
Okay.
That guy's crying.
The two 13 countdown.
Ah,
I see.
There you go.
That's it for time.
[inaudible] now
this is [inaudible] is this is um,
eh.
Okay.
Especially at,
I don't know how Yo Joey's back heel.
Yeah.
What's impressive is that your endurance has gone
better cause he's a god,
aren't they
all?
Ah,
to repeat on my whole like how much of that is conditional work and how much of
that is just knowing how to pace yourself better?
One Door Soa.
Oh,
book.
Do like when they show shown to your support to my home.
Mine.
He got smarter.
Yeah.
Mine.
Knowing how to pace yourself,
knowing when to explode.
One,
not one.
No one go about my day.
Was it?
What did you say to Luke?
Rockhold after you knocked him out,
you were like,
you were on top of him talking to him.
Luke Rockhold.
You know,
because
y'all know y'all and kill with the people.
How they colleague Kutik a code coat.
Yeah.
You know,
I told you that I stay,
we day
15 years within my urbanize together.
Right.
You know,
or you needed respite.
Okay.
Right.
You need respect that
tiny people talk shit over here.
Yeah.
And when you cross deny how's this,
is this better now?
Right.
And then it becomes personal.
Yeah.
You can fight with me every day.
But see,
you have a card coat.
It's not problem.
Right.
It's a sport.
Right,
right.
It's a spot.
But when you group the lines,
you stay with me here,
an outside and an and
you give them a hug,
you put your arm around them.
Why late it Jude Token Thompson?
No good about me.
Right.
Why
do you think that in America,
particularly today in the UFC,
this is common because it gets guys attention and they see like Conor McGregor
who makes a lot of money because not just the visibility cause he could fight
really well,
but also because he talks shit really well to Timmy.
I understand a little bit,
but I wanted him Moses.
Why USC Guy Handicap long anyway,
I called them Lando for sure.
For sure.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
Listen going on his collar,
right corner.
This corner.
That's why.
That's the way you say I know many people like him like a corner and and and,
and in Cuba and the national team.
Many people they days,
right.
This is what I see right now.
Yeah,
Paul.
Okay.
You have to be [inaudible] what he's saying right now,
he's already lived.
He's already saying this.
The quite stay in 15 years at together.
No,
no sir.
Only wrestling.
Listen,
not only for wrestling thing is
sport to get it all the sports together.
Everybody together.
Yeah.
You can be savages.
Wallman mn together.
Good luck.
Shot again.
Yeah.
I bought it.
The best of the best jewel.
Kay limb
able to second.
Hmm.
Do
you do a King?
[inaudible] he was there 15 years and he learned every fucking second that
you're there.
You'll learn it.
Dang dude.
The put him in and he might be not quite not,
they can't [inaudible] didn't get to say that shit.
I ain't got nothing.
[inaudible]
meadows for you to be there,
you have to be in the top four.
So that's the pressure
to get them to the part of the metal,
the top four and every division and every sport.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I'm not a,
I'm not a tonic.
You're losing this position.
For example,
in soccer,
you come on time.
I broke down the block.
Okay too.
Then number four,
you are number four go.
But out of sight,
they don't bust my ass.
Whooped.
Got Your went harder.
Two more came out
and I said she on that guy,
that protein.
20 people,
the Templo,
a soccer playing soccer.
Tim,
I think it's steady or 24 people.
I think so teddy people.
So you're number three,
you're number three.
He said,
not a guy.
He said the bed and another company in another city.
They said,
okay,
you know number three and now I know that guy.
He push you,
you need him off.
You didn't move.
He coming and you go,
you go home,
you're gone.
You don't understand.
That's it.
Not just give up.
So the pressure is intense.
So 15 years.
I am.
See many people come and go,
ah,
well chunk time that people,
this jail is good and that idea and this to here and three here,
this guy's coming in again because he's beat it.
It's better said,
hey,
hey man,
you come by here
for it.
They're not as Paul.
No,
only wrestling.
Right.
I understand.
I can your boiler,
we read come.
He could live with this or what's going on.
I thought you said he had gone live with the competition.
You're going to look at,
look at,
stopped by something other than you've ever seen.
He couldn't live with it and it's no big fucking deal.
Many people know who I am to make it the same.
What are they going to do it right,
but cooler.
This corner.
They're not [inaudible].
They're faking it.
Yeah.
I say
this,
I make it clear for corner.
That's just the thing.
I said him and now she made me,
he wa she hasn't necessarily get out cause had choir.
They see fake.
You're not because [inaudible] is no like this.
Well,
it's interesting like Anderson Silva made it to the top without ever talking.
Shit never talked shit.
Anderson Silva was always respectful people.
People went to see him and bought his paper review just because he was a bad
mother fucker and they wanted to see him fight.
It was a hundred percent based on this ability to happen,
the fight
and it's on beat two bedroom [inaudible] yeah,
this is not fun.
Yeah.
That's just not fight.
You understand.
Right.
He's quiet back this day.
He says,
yeah,
he put it there then the Moscow Moscow and now that's just not funny.
He know he know needed imitation corner.
Cause Vito was saying that Anderson was fake and he wears a mask and that's not
who he really is.
You understand?
So Anderson took it very personally.
Yeah.
Personally.
I never see and it's own like this.
No,
that was very professional.
You understand?
That's a way you say.
Yeah.
And now the people want the money.
No Man,
you do,
you know,
comment [inaudible] you a fire.
Right.
You fight it and kill the people.
Take it,
the hand there and Amano and now the paper pay you.
Right.
Well now that when you go fight again,
the people pay pepper bill because the people want to see you.
Right?
The people don't want to,
you and I,
okay,
so you want to say something?
Say by not,
not Eh.
[inaudible] no,
don't imitate.
You know,
there's too many people.
There's definitely a lot of people that were doing that,
doing a bad job of it.
It's okay if we look at the way he thought,
Luke Rockhold
man [inaudible] again,
I say,
hey look,
and now you're seeing and now you'll remember.
Why are you taking me?
And you say you are,
go to our hunger.
We'll go out,
we'll do the party.
And when you stay with me,
you say me.
Hey,
you want to fire me?
He said No.
Why?
You asked me why you ask say no,
you want to fight with me?
She doesn't know the question.
The question is you want to find me.
So this is before the fight.
You guys had a conversation long time,
long time ago,
and he said he didn't want to fight you.
He say he know want to fire me.
He said,
okay Bro,
she,
you know,
won't find me.
I know if I you,
you understand what,
what was that about?
Why would you guys say that?
Why would you have this conversation or you're in the same division?
Yeah.
Why would he say that he doesn't want to fight you.
I don't know.
You need it.
Ask Him.
No,
me.
Because I know [inaudible] Sala competitors here,
he's going to start the conversation.
Right.
Okay.
You need to ask him.
Right.
Okay.
Because I know you stay in me in the same car and the same division.
Right.
She,
you know what if I me lose it.
Oh,
she didn't want to stay.
If you don't want to fight,
right.
Either go up.
Yeah,
go,
oh,
I'll lose it.
Right.
So you wing.
I am when the financier boom,
right.
If and I,
when we're going to have to fight.
So when you finally did fight him.
Dot was when
you felt he was disrespectful.
He was talking to a lot of shit.
That's it.
What I think
on things they get [inaudible]
uh,
before what happened with do Sada
[inaudible] that's what happened every time when he said me,
explain to people what happened.
You got Ahold of a tainted supplement.
There was something in the supplement that was
on that.
It was in the supplement.
So you got cleared.
It's like you had a small suspension.
Mr No food is,
if it's a supplement,
you're going to talk to Mondo.
He was
bullied,
might not understand what happened.
And they said,
because this superman I take,
right,
I take it.
Why does superman have something forbidding in it?
Yeah.
Why?
Why not before,
right.
Well,
it's very common and a lot of times what happens is the suppliers,
when you,
uh,
save your supplement company and you have someone make some stuff for you and
then you package it and sell it,
the people that are putting it together for you,
they're selling a bunch of other things too.
And oftentimes things get into your supplement that aren't supposed to be there.
Especially same.
No.
Timmy
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] to [inaudible] pub with them being,
they said that when people see me,
yeah,
he,
Tommy know this has happened to a lot of guys.
Question the question,
is it true I could go into GNC and buy shit that could get jack?
Yes.
GNC,
yes.
I've heard you talking on the podcast,
not when I'm on,
but other people.
Yeah,
so I could go into GNC and takes the guy guys.
A lot of stuff that you go,
if you go into GNC,
you'll buy stuff that's on the shelves for a little while and then they pull it
and a,
when companies sell stuff to them,
sometimes they'll say there's one thing in it,
but there's other things in it as well.
That's a real common thing,
especially if something works really well.
Like a lot of times the stuff that works really well,
people find out.
Yeah,
it works really well because it's fucking steroids in it.
you could,
I mean it might not just be GNC,
just any vitamin store.
No,
not necessarily GNC,
but there's a bunch of illegal steroids at Gnc,
vitamin Shoppe and Walmart and more.
Yeah.
See,
this is very,
very common when you,
when you go to these places and buy these things,
there's a lot of stuff at a regular vitamin store that'll make you test positive
by Usada.
You'll test for banned substances from stuff you just buying a store.
Yo,
you know,
many times I think after this happened,
I think in many time imputation people from Cuba take it.
People say,
okay,
you are,
you are you,
you and you come to Cuba for maybe 20 days.
I wanted the people see because
the genetic for Cuba off the charts.
No.
For the no,
for the athletic people.
None of them.
Normally everybody normal.
Yeah.
Normal people imitation.
You need to see,
see an open mind.
Right.
He know.
That's what I say.
Well,
here's how much pain you need to pay for the soup for the [inaudible].
Come on,
man.
They don't have the money.
Come on man.
Come on,
man.
Did people don't have,
don't have anything.
I know what you're saying.
The other thing is you could take all the steroids in the world.
You're not going to look like you the way a person like you looks.
It has to be genetics,
[inaudible]
genetics.
It took a regular guy and gave him steroids.
You would never look like you if they do go home people not what I meant to the
methods.
Thyroid,
no sell high buy the second book that yeah,
there's a lot of it is genetics and a lot of it is also,
you got to think from the time you were little,
you were involved in this intense athletic program.
Your body develop that way.
Can easy.
They could do the whole fico to neck to get dual equipped portfolio [inaudible]
cause it's Yotpo.
[inaudible]
no,
I wanted it.
No,
believe me,
I want to do it.
This,
that,
that invitation people from Kip.
I wonder,
do people see you want them to go sir?
Yeah.
I wanted,
I wanted to say and I want to see after after.
No,
no,
because this is my second full day for me.
You know I wanted to,
after they,
when I train it,
they,
when I beat him the barrel
because you know,
can put it everything what you're doing and to beat it with the people.
She I do a ds,
he did this and now he can be to him.
You understand what I say?
Yes.
Okay.
I wanted the imputation camera for me for three months.
Yeah.
For three months.
I never take it.
Nothing.
And now you see what I do understand.
Stop Talking Shit.
You understand?
So people accused you of taking steroids after the tainted supplement thing,
but you've never tested positive before or after.
Aye.
I do for,
for the Olympic Commission test,
the [inaudible] from 95 he's been testing for the Olympics.
Did they mean by the woman picks?
I'm sorry.
Right.
I know [inaudible] never,
he never came up positive,
you know?
But the thing is when someone looks at you,
cause you have so much muscle,
they assume you're doing something.
They'll get the meat at least saying I in the winter.
And if Jordan can you get out that said,
okay,
you have to me told me don't go
knock
on the door.
Yeah,
the people phase where there's smoke,
there's fire where the people think that if you're doing that,
can I just interject here for a second?
Cause Look Aoa seed by saying that I said I'll probably bio III.
I see.
Look here it was,
I don't really know.
Sorry.
Did I say I'm not a racist.
I grew up with a lot of Cuban guys,
this dark skinned guys and uh,
it's amazing.
But then you see somebody like to me when I look at a physical specimen,
I always compare it to Dave winfield.
You Remember Day Jordan feel,
can I have a picture of the day when field a baseball player,
you know,
six foot seven baseball player ran bases,
you know on the other hand can say call had to do 4.4 and he did the 40 yard
dash and all that.
But to me this is just me and I hope I don't get in trouble for saying this.
Look at day Winfield's baseball body.
He was sick.
I saw him arrest from once.
That picture that you just had up Jamie.
Yeah,
right there,
man.
Look the fucking leg.
Africa,
it's a fucking huge country and God knows what God knows what came through cube
and what we developed and how we develop like,
you know,
and,
and you know what,
what you need,
you know,
then you have Earl Campbell.
What tribe in Africa at all?
Campbell come with Herschel Walker.
Herschel Walker.
Still 52 years in age.
He's jacked.
You know,
are you saying that her,
she was fucking juicer.
You know,
these people went through cube,
but now you add that with the no feeding because these guys don't have the best
nutrition in the world in Cuba.
They don't have to,
you know,
what are you hearing now that even the Cuban cigars aren't that good anymore?
Cause the dirt isn't that good.
You know,
it's a fucking poor country.
It's not like they get water,
vitamin,
water,
uh,
what's his name was down and you know,
so you have to take all those things.
You know,
these guys lived on Dick,
let me see something.
You know why when I did people,
many people know he is.
Um,
he's the guy,
he's got this one 71 71 Tyron Woodley.
No,
no,
no.
We told her to stay in Cuba training.
Oh my brown.
Yeah.
He know this.
Yes.
You know what the people take it after the fact,
after the training.
Like a recover to recover.
Yeah.
Like gay,
gay Jody,
something like this.
Right.
Are you ready for what he's going to tell you what they drink to recover
what they see.
Doesn't that I'm sitting down?
Yeah.
I walk on water with sugar water.
Sure.
Wow.
Low tech people gay
because you haven't nothing,
they don't have nothing.
They have nothing.
So you never saw any steroid use and go out on Lincoln [inaudible] and you never
saw any athletes.
Listen,
two,
sorry.
Even central in Bingo.
You know how many people are the Olympic silo
where all the sports are?
Okay.
Thing got going to see me.
And do you think of going to see me that he has the consciousness?
[inaudible] has his 15 years as an athlete.
Cadelle k those [inaudible] that two cases came up positive.
Wow.
And go up and go on pink Cuba at of all those years.
Two cases.
He don't unless like I don't know.
I don't know.
Like I don't have any,
which I tell them the base on one guy was in a weightlifter angled.
This young boy.
I hate him there.
Why he though that?
They called them like a country motherfucker.
Crazy.
He was crazy.
I heat up y'all for marijuana and the other guy was positive for marijuana.
Yeah.
It great.
You don't get okay.
Cut.
Okay.
Yo,
what's the deal boy that started on testosterone.
He was positive for Telstra.
How common is marijuana in Cuba?
I mooch on money.
You want to go up?
noise.
Alright,
so do not want to hand me that if you start looking at it.
Sorry.
But I know soccer snuck one for the Cubans.
There's a lot of marijuana.
Hmm.
Okay.
Michelle arena,
his niece,
new collector.
Nobody wanted to hear,
never saw a pop plan or wife Michelle.
We didn't,
not no sign and look at assessing his nephew doesn't even know what it is.
New Guy said [inaudible] he didn't never even heard people speak about it.
Pedal Quando to us.
Um,
and this tree,
when you go on the streets,
you know me,
I can't decide.
Right.
Okay.
Sit down that night.
That's how I look at some Becker said he'll look,
pick petco up,
but it goes,
hey,
went up our street.
Percocet.
People know what the saying that people street the people is marijuana illegal
in Cuba illegally.
You get in big trouble.
Big Trevor,
Trevor and Joe.
Okay.
They,
yeah.
Well seeing God says,
listen,
I'll take you through a hundred houses and might see d he not that real.
She ain't causes,
he didn't go home.
We just Cheetos and he'll get kids.
He sets,
I order he SAS outer maybe now beat.
That's what she is.
Him on the telephone pole.
Okay.
The whole society and the whole world's gonna fucking crazy.
Right.
[inaudible] and media for his era there in Cuba.
And I can't take two
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and you let them talk and nobody wanted
them.
So I'll be able to get them.
And you can go to a hundred kids and take two other each house and ask nothing
on marijuana and they don't know what it is.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pedal.
But I'm wearing throws his demo for his head.
Now the system we live in [inaudible] north
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and start compared to what it's like here,
but like muddy.
Why does marijuana when all on motley went to Cuba.
The band goes on my way from La.
He told me he copped be cops on weight in Cuba.
I would be so fucking scared.
Yeah,
I wouldn't fuck you get locked up.
For example,
money,
one of them.
Oh,
what's that look like?
Just how much time they give you the DSR and Tanya from 10 to 20 years
for one joint.
Oh,
okay.
Fuck that.
Ooh.
She got her oof one mile.
She Shay.
Um,
in your UFC career you had one very controversial fight with,
uh,
Tim Kennedy.
That time where you sat on the stool for a long time,
like an extra 30 seconds in between the rounds.
What's,
what's your take on that?
Can
he get Tim [inaudible] Bingo photo,
get muscle
I
to call ego [inaudible] he call you go.
They bought deal.
He has two colleagues in his life.
College colleagues from the street and colleagues from the sport.
Okay.
You looked at it and get it into,
I saw most of them have to go hand in hand.
Okay.
You could all get Nadia in Angola.
He doesn't think he has any of those.
What?
What does that mean?
Rondo meters loose.
He was holding onto his fingers and he go out and grabbed your glove
group
for that before for that?
Yeah.
And I'm gonna ha they were against the fence.
Okay.
And mythology under one Tommy,
he was following his guy.
So he's cheating.
Yeah,
but are you
okay?
It's my throat.
Jonathan are going to heck come on a car.
It's his fault because he didn't have to let him grab his fucking gloves.
Right.
Do you want me to organize a fun?
He let him grab your shirt and then he grabbed his yellow,
the hardware for the,
he turned my glove.
He turned my glove.
He sold the moms in my glove.
He's,
hold on.
You grabbed his glove.
He told the referee.
Yes.
Hey,
stay like this guy.
He's going up against the wall.
Let me,
let me remember.
Take it that morning.
That now they're against the fence.
Okay.
[inaudible] guantee he grabs his hair first.
Your to grip your shirt on and he grabbed
my glove.
Robert.
He lives it.
He lets it go up right away so they can apply it,
right?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Bento 15 seconds left.
Five email grabbed his glove,
but now boom,
boom.
Hit your head.
Yeah.
There's a video of that.
He's going to ask you a question.
Okay.
See [inaudible] if he sticks his finger in your fucking I get calls.
I said,
so what is that?
It's a foul foul.
How many minutes do you need it for the you recover?
It's a good question.
Depending on how bad your eyes or hurt it might be over KDC that bring them
[inaudible].
We don't want to quite lamentable.
How long would it be?
I took a few minutes.
Okay.
All right.
[inaudible] if he kicks you in the balls,
took a few minutes.
Take a few minutes.
Okay.
I that and I said the one thing [inaudible] guy grabbing gloves.
Is it legal to know Google?
Okay.
She tell you in Garpy one day
Cabasa if he punches you,
wear your gloves.
I want me holding on to your gloves if I'm punching you and I'm bawling on to
you.
Glove.
Is that illegally illegal?
Illegal.
Okay.
[inaudible] Mario,
how much time should have taken off?
So what you're saying is you sat down for extra time in between the rounds
because he committed a foul right before that.
No,
no,
no gentleman gas on top.
What
he's asking you a question.
She,
we said say they would have stopped it,
but CLR Boudreau [inaudible]
cutout.
If she had I been doing SMEs to,
if the judge would have seen that came Mary [inaudible] ligament,
that he would've seen him ripping off his glove.
He gave me me and said,
I was so hoping he would've seen him punching him like,
no,
my mentor went to the input and the organization's not you.
How much time would he have taken?
Well,
he should take points away.
This is what I think.
I think anytime someone does a foul,
you just take points away,
click on the old deck,
kicking the balls,
point away,
poke in the eye,
point away.
Because even if you don't mean to do it,
even if you don't mean to do it,
the loss of sync,
get it.
It's still does damage and it's a foul foul.
So I think you should get a point taken away.
My Jamaica,
he didn't say it.
She,
she knows me.
See?
No,
he has a bad ally.
Bet She listen now,
but the fight ended poke a second.
I want gimbal because of the time,
and she know Julia,
but if not,
he would have lost the fight.
Right,
because you were hurt.
He punches him,
my boom.
See,
not by their name.
It's like,
oh,
did you already said lucid?
They fight at the time when the end that he would've lost the fun.
So
round was over.
You sat down between rounds.
What happened?
[inaudible] stay here and clean egg on the yolk sac.
How I can't book when the time and made it clear.
They lean pillow stay right there and clean them.
But my gut is intelligent.
My could you say I know can do it.
No.
Boiling bellow.
So your coach bought you extra time,
bad or Norfolk by and I as she,
dude,
I made out.
They thought the Yang.
Okay,
you watch it?
No,
no,
no.
[inaudible] his trainer couldn't clean them,
couldn't wipe them and they said,
you're the [inaudible] protocol.
He said,
no,
no.
Don't tell him you're dead.
Mondo [inaudible]
like it.
Emma.
Oh,
the guy that was supposed to wipe him down was to cut math,
but the cup man couldn't do it.
So then the other guy had to come [inaudible] the cup man had left already.
[inaudible] just the only two that were in the ring with a tool trainers.
Ian [inaudible].
He said,
John up well go God.
[inaudible] he said,
I tell you even got here.
So did they cover you with water to give you extra time to do it?
That they don't want to show up out there?
My tempo,
no hidden preliminal do they sound them?
So I don't think she really know anything.
I mean,
he's always done the water exclusively in his trainings and cruciate.
And I will see him [inaudible] on recover.
He likes the water for recovery.
[inaudible] it tells people to wipe them down.
Right now I ain't put on my temple and put out your record.
I'm,
it's not for more,
it's for him to
recover.
Right.
Go onto
[inaudible] [inaudible] recovery Maldonado I get really is motto Aria,
I guess
you have to throw the water on it.
[inaudible] I'm Imodium Ben with the towels on them and to wipe it down at the
same Coolum off the,
call them off.
Right?
So at the end of the round,
the round ends,
you're sitting on the corner of the round,
supposed to begin.
Tim Kennedy standing up and he's like,
what is going on here?
He thinks maybe the fights over and you're still sitting.
Why know he wanted to fight to be,
oh yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Okay.
LTC.
Qiagen hello
and
no getting up.
Tim,
Tim in and modify them.
Gerawan thread messes.
UFC Lindsey,
I take it they fight and made the three,
uh,
the UFC mix.
[inaudible] first he said he had an injury.
They want to fight.
So it took three months for him to fight you out.
Right.
But he could have had an injury he grabbed by the ranger.
It is possible pool diarrhea.
No,
he's not saying it right.
Right,
right,
right.
Pocket.
Because they gave him the fight three times.
You didn't want it.
He always something always was I talking to [inaudible] until he finally took
the fight?
No.
Two,
sorry.
I tell you,
Tom Casey,
I know Lydia [inaudible] 15 years dealing with people say Como Se money fitter
you,
he knows how they're going to manifest ea to Dominique [inaudible] in the
beginning he was very nice.
Oh,
you're married.
I weighed in,
I beside the way in the way and just,
I don't kill him.
He's staying in their mind.
His business put,
Oh,
can I?
Okay.
Get all get up in epilepsy.
Mcgregor.
Whoa.
The main car was poor ea McGregor stock and it was hot.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Bna Ma.
Hey Yo.
See Ladies.
Hey,
please,
please not do this.
Can I see
you knew she had on troll.
Who said that to you?
They do that.
Tim Did.
So like,
let's be professional.
Let's
right.
Hey,
hey.
Hey.
What was that?
Please not do this.
He said,
well,
why not do it right?
[inaudible] I said,
[inaudible] [inaudible] why will he come up to him and say that if the whole
time he's been very respectful at Tim Kennedy,
right?
I don't know.
Because he wants to talk.
You know,
like a friend.
Some weight loss.
Get sales.
I'm getting a divorce.
The Games are they used in sports to try to be your friend?
Yeah,
that's it.
[inaudible] when we were in the fight,
she threw me in a van number later.
If you watched the fight around,
you'll know an FRC.
The first round,
he wanted easy say,
well no,
don't get the gun under the wrong.
He's second round.
He's fight.
He's willing to fight us.
Knew he has his
[inaudible] [inaudible] he said he's like,
oh wrong.
[inaudible] that wouldn't have happened with the grab glove.
He would've won the second round.
And also him grabbing your glove is how he was able to hit you.
Yeah,
he knew and [inaudible] he didn't touch him in the whole fight.
Right.
That's what I meant.
Just in those last 10 seconds.
He Mental Golean Ludo whether you get them real fucking hard.
So when you were sitting there,
what was going through your mind when you were sitting there and Tim Kennedy was
telling you to stand up and you knew that the round was over or the rest period
was over.
[inaudible] Tim [inaudible] you can look at the top and inside panic domain.
Get out my wife Daggum anything to relax.
I'm going to get up as soon as they fucking wipe me down.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he and and reality and think that Tim,
can you make it?
He had guys in the states.
Okay,
your three pence.
I'm the way that he was thinking,
Hey guys,
[inaudible] academy now he wants to come out to finish knocking me out,
right.
You know all the things that got them
through everything.
He's saying,
okay,
how come I didn't bring out all that?
Let me let,
let me dry me off and then we'll fucking fight.
Right.
But there was only,
you only get one minute rest.
You were hurt at the end of the round.
There's only one minute rest.
But you took a minute and 30 seconds.
That extra 30 seconds had to help.
Cause he said [inaudible] [inaudible] but [inaudible] why not?
I said,
God,
I can see.
Yeah,
fuck yeah,
but enough for me.
Good problem is not his fault.
It's not your fault.
Let me go see,
see,
see you as a third lien bill.
If he would have been cleaned up and my colleague Tyler left,
then they can set it up and get them started with the set.
Go out and fight going to me the appointment.
Bill McCarthy.
Good video on my God,
my car.
Did he say go put it up on golf,
man,
they get 33 when he go,
he sees
and he stopped the 15 day you told him to slow down.
So you're saying that that was not a ploy in order to get you more arrest
Eczema?
I don't know a whole lot of that.
No,
no,
no.
Come on.
No,
no,
no.
For sure.
So the only other fight,
well that,
that was a,
that was a controversial moment.
You said that in the Robert Whitaker fight,
that was a very,
there was a experience for you.
You will,
cause you went five rounds,
came very close to winning the interim title,
but came short.
Like what did you,
what did you get out of that fight?
Do you said there was a big learning experience for you?
They say,
because if we're a good lip at data with a guy through the hate,
the [inaudible] will not black at two,
two.
That was a big learning experience because going fine,
she'll be fine with Joel and I will not buy last set.
Got it up.
But I like that we have for housing called rounds.
Uh,
last night his managers said that after the fight,
when he saw him,
that he had a big smile on his face,
that one of his
content to see,
he was very happy.
He didn't take that last as serious as he should have booked.
Get to dock on dental.
Is that same where they lose it one day you learn that
and now you see what happened
with Luke Rockhold.
Yeah.
What did you learn in the Robert Whitaker fight about the timing,
timing,
timing.
You need it in a more calm down,
Lisa.
The people talk about my gas,
right?
But
the most,
what does that look at?
I'm being pulled that same team
Calu Rocco,
cal,
bill and up and they're getting this down.
Farcical,
my pencil.
Well,
the other thing was that
Luke Rockhold didn't,
it wasn't as easy as it was to fight this fucking guy.
You know,
he saw that it wasn't that easy.
Hmm.
Can I go get my salary?
Joe Jr on lean more than [inaudible] metal.
[inaudible] now he fed NCI,
mi manager middle.
He had a meal.
Quando [inaudible] Johnny called you over training was in Albuquerque with Jon
Jones Jovi.
He saw something.
I let come through lava.
No,
haddock is they control this attacks.
Quando when David [inaudible],
when he,
when he should attack,
he's learned that from John [inaudible] meal and that hadn't happened.
With that,
go,
go.
[inaudible] go,
go,
go nursing on monkey.
Now not going to tell you what,
if you tell somebody,
go,
go.
Then I'll fucking machine looking like a fucking tie.
That's what happened.
You had to learn to pace yourself and don't say [inaudible] sync around.
Believe me.
Never.
Never worried about five bucks because I training everyday to ticket.
Then they program.
I see two solid community in his gas.
You didn't,
you didn't get that political power
staff.
What?
You have to be worried if he didn't know that you don't have gas in that.
I know have it programmed for five.
Come on.
The argument has always been the guy who has more muscle has a harder time
keeping a fast paced.
So what you've learned how to do is to pace yourself for your body type.
Does that make sense?
Decent Gullah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] bye bye for hot.
Say Lulu both cause look at too tired to tell these gender.
All I can do up to deal [inaudible] I can't think of that.
You know the,
the like a soccer group shot.
Remember when he fought?
No,
no.
The black dude with the crazy.
So could you,
so could you,
I mean when I show the show,
could you,
I turned the TV off.
I was so fucking scared.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I just turned the TV off.
Yeah,
he was a beast.
But after around and a half,
it contains a lot of oxygen.
I've learned that from you talking about the UFC that you need a lot of the
oxygen.
[inaudible]
no,
I'm going to class.
How many mouths to taking Minnie mouse,
Minnie mouse.
The mouse
[inaudible] go,
go,
go.
Even have to tell him please.
You know,
but,
but to have all that muscle has,
it takes more endurance.
Right?
[inaudible] go ahead,
Mike.
To pay off is you have much more power and a lot by law.
I honestly,
I load my poet,
she come on,
come on.
The old team was looking at my boy can nail.
Okay,
going to clean because when people look at the thing and they'll pop Micah,
Micah,
mouse,
but I load the more direct that that thick.
She,
she,
she for sure.
So you've learned how to pace yourself for your body type and your style and now
like that five rounds with Whitaker.
That was a big learning experience for you in that way.
Yeah.
So now you're going to fight Whitaker again.
Yes.
You look very excited.
I think if you win,
you will be the oldest guy to ever,
well,
maybe Randy couture when he won the heavyweight title,
but for sure middleweight you'll definitely be the oldest middleweight.
I think Randy was older when he won the heavyweight title when he,
my whole middle that,
oh yeah.
See,
I think Randy was (404) 064-0640 six Jesus Christ.
And he was a beast.
He's the band.
Yeah.
Fight was the first light heavyweight since losing to check his first fight.
It led to everyone around the beam,
the oldest fighter win a UFC belt.
No,
no,
no.
That's the EOC bout.
No,
no,
that's not what I meant.
Look at one.
He,
how old was he when he beat Tim Silvia?
I had championed typed in us before.
Find out he was when he be [inaudible].
You want it to be,
I think he was,
I want to say it was 44 I want to say it was 44 I think he might've been,
yeah,
45 and four months.
45 45 damn.
So He'd beat Tim Silvia for the heavyweight title when he's 45 now all due
respect,
you have to remember that there was the testing back then.
They just look at and yeah,
he look clean.
Just don't fucking testing.
They test you at the weigh ins.
That was it.
There was no random testing.
It was no usada it's a different ball game now.
As far as guys getting tested.
Yeah.
He gets tested the most and the UFC really [inaudible] cause look at you
man.
Like I wish I'm mad dog two times a month.
Two Times a month.
Wow.
Male.
He Sung it.
JC piss and blood.
They just show up and say by that,
sorry.
Right now
all of us are going to get pissed.
Don't mix this test.
So we're going to have a real private,
you know,
it's a funny and
New York.
It's in New York,
Um,
and if I would,
uh,
Chris,
Chris Weidman.
Yeah.
On the it like right.
I got the test.
You right after you flexed
only amazing.
Come on.
Well,
New York,
they just,
you know,
that was new.
New York is very new to MMA.
I mean they might have had a couple of years now.
It's a funny,
like a monster,
monster,
monster energy drink.
Say on my manager.
Oh look,
it is guy,
man.
He's dead bones.
That and when I go out is a Zack come on most of that.
I said,
come on monster.
So we're going to test you yet.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's Hilarious,
man.
Do you think it's a good thing?
Do you side of testing?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yup.
Good.
Keep everybody honest.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That Chris Weidman fight.
That was one of your most spectacular knockouts.
Deaf flying knee.
Thank you.
Whoo.
That's crazy you.
That's one thing that's unique about you is your ability to just explode out of
nowhere.
Like you love guys to sleep in the den and then,
and then he'd go off me.
Yeah.
That's your style.
So unique style man.
And what did you wrestle but like that too?
Oh my God.
By then.
Well,
my thought.
Bingo.
That's it.
You know,
it's dependent.
When my coach,
the wrestling coach Giani
[inaudible] Papa,
but him,
when I do charge of that,
he,
he said,
hey,
go.
I am
attack.
I talk.
I tell them,
eh,
that's it.
What I want to do.
And you haven't made the difference is though the wrestling is shorter time
periods.
But I told him no striking.
I wanted to do that.
Lisa
did people w lappers you're not gonna make an awesome.
The people who know him,
I brought him in on,
I ain't gonna be me.
Yes.
Mostly now.
And then watch him train [inaudible] and being [inaudible].
They know how he fights Gando coma.
[inaudible].
How's he fight with percentages or his
EA?
Yeah.
I think that's Yada Yada.
No.
K.
[inaudible].
Okay.
Y'All.
But I think all day you don't get the idea anyway.
That's how your Porto,
he thanks God for everything.
Plato.
You have any of that?
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
He,
Oh yeah.
He was coming back and gets up and now
in the winter graphite you were coming back.
She took way a middle is,
I wonder,
I looked him around if you watched the last round where that made outlet quite
don't the fourth round he had Kinda,
how does it come out in the fifth round?
And it's a joy put up a random if at all,
no matter what.
But if I handle being in Como and he was preparing himself but he wasn't
prepared himself correctly,
I tend to now she may be [inaudible] Como Open here.
This little trainer really gets him prepared.
How he should fight.
What is different?
Can look at it though.
Okay.
[inaudible] um,
my [inaudible] that under low cinco round like this bow,
bow.
Bow.
Wow.
He was trying to find a high pace for five routes.
Okay,
go knock on the glass because he knows his gas,
you know right
now I can't,
they look up,
look up a level c c getting set on that though.
If they want to be honest.
They bring let's head CFRC no,
no,
no.
The independent demand.
He said [inaudible] [inaudible] tell him whether they went on,
lost them all under the gas.
The gas she had [inaudible] every mobile Marbella if it's as easy to get that
rhythm going,
okay,
I'm not going to hit that four day.
Then turnover.
There's one thing to be out of the fight and I was wanting to be in the fight
and don't say
come up.
Ah,
ah,
ah.
Let's just wait till June 9th.
June 9th.
That's when it's going to be,
where is it?
Chicago.
Ooh.
Ooh,
you're there.
June 8th.
Yeah.
Excited.
What is different about your preparation now?
Get loud.
[inaudible]
um,
just,
sorry.
No,
no,
no.
See Demos.
The internal Manto,
the system for training.
[inaudible] the ones that are utilizing.
Now going back to this Cuban roots,
why does this guy,
this a new coach have better results with older athletes?
Okay.
Eh,
eh.
[inaudible] Google her suit.
[inaudible]
noise.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it's like a look at this.
Okay.
She [inaudible] um,
he can help get our logo.
Awesome.
Do you think will Mucho,
Mucho,
Mucho.
[inaudible]
not,
you know,
if you ask him that,
the train of this,
he's got a lot of training and experiences.
Body already know
tuneup way.
[inaudible] you can't make him do an 18 year old does,
right?
[inaudible] fico something specific.
No.
[inaudible] hundred matter our Bessie fico on specifics right now.
Then [inaudible] he doesn't need to run 20 laps around a fucking track,
you know,
it's all good.
Martha.
I think got them.
All that's going to do is fuck him up.
Do you run it all to corporate?
See how many miles?
What about seeing about God at I'm a Korean.
The mannose Ganti now we're running less than before.
[inaudible] Pacifica,
we're running a certain oh,
specific way.
Homeowner specific because talking about how much longer do you think you're
going to be finding your 41 when do you think you're going to retire?
Can you say [inaudible] [inaudible] what was Doria?
Okay.
You know when you do,
when you're 20,
you have a discipline
on the data.
They see Polina,
you have discipline and [inaudible]
and [inaudible] train everyday.
[inaudible] when you train every day on the other [inaudible] God made lake
one day you wake up,
God,
Jesus,
everything hurts.
Everything hurts.
Swing.
Yes.
Even my,
my toenails heard
a little d about ticketing a discipline
in Hong Kong and no matter if you train every day and you're tired and
everything saw you have a compromise,
you've,
you've committed to something.
It does.
A lab room does a taekwondo.
I said until one is this,
uh,
this commitment kind of be for him.
He saw us,
Donna digital,
he hopes to win the title,
but I [inaudible] I didn't ask him after he wins a title.
No.
Uh,
okay.
See me well equipped because yeah,
he saw his body hurts.
Okay.
Internet bullying training hurts.
When you train for real,
it hurts sometimes.
32 years,
the owners.
That's crazy.
It's a long time.
You look great.
Thank you brother.
You hanging in there?
Well,
listen man.
June 9th I can't wait to watch.
Robert Whitaker is a great fighter,
a great fighter.
It should be a fantastic fight for the UFC middleweight championship and good
luck to you,
my brother Joey Diaz.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] and setting this up was beautiful.
Thank you everybody love you guys.
Love you guys.
And girls.